there he is brian dawkins aka weapon x
getting the chris
one of the best defensive players in nfl
history member of the pro football hall
of fame and here he is
with us at pro football talk live in
miami for the super bowl a former
teammate chris simpson one of my
favorite teammates ever i don't know i'm
sure he doesn't feel the same way but i
knew i was in the presence of a hall of
famer and a guy that
mike i'm just gonna say it and i know
you've heard me say this before it's the
greatest transformation of a human being
on a weekly basis you could ever imagine
because brian is soft-spoken he's a
great man a great leader but i can still
remember week one of the nfl season that
year in denver and i walked into the
locker room and i went where did that
soft smoking nice guy go because
wolverine came out that's right and it
is unbelievable the biggest game day
transformation ever and i'm still amazed
by how you did that how did that happen
was it natural or did you have to did
you have to like pull the cord on the
lawnmower to get it going no there is no
cords matter of fact i had to like hold
myself back a lot i figured same day as
as it got closer and closer to that time
to go out to to do what i needed to do i
had to hold that energy in and the
reason why i used to scream so much
because i was trying to get some of the
energy out you had so much energy ball
to bottled up but you know what it's
it's the love of the game i loved it so
much i was blessed to do it at a high
level and
it was wasn't too many things i would
not do for my teammates i don't care if
i know i only played in denver for three
years but for those three years whatever
i can do for that team i was gonna do it
and i tried my best to yeah i mean he he
was he was the leader of the locker room
almost instantaneously i mean he knew he
was the leader of the locker room mike
he had two lockers okay he got two
lockers one for brian dawkins and then
one for all his wolverine stuff next to
it he added all of it there all of it
there so uh but it was amazing watching
b dock i mean you're the man and uh i
love my time
you're with the eagles for super bowl 39
andy reid the head coach what's the one
immediate memory that comes to mind when
you think of your experience in
jacksonville in that game no we lost
that's the immediate relax
reaction that i get um you know
obviously to beat atlanta to get there
in the first place was huge because we
had at that time i think we lost what
three in a row three nfc championships
in a game in a row three or four
at that time and so to finally get past
that hump to get there was a thrill in
itself to be back home in jacksonville
was a thrill to be back
but
the end result was was we lost and so to
have him back in this with this
opportunity to win um is true tremendous
and you know i know for me i'm going to
share some tears if that happens for him
big time if you if you went back i mean
that was a great eagles team you had uh
obviously to to go to all the
championship games and finally get to
the super bowl you think if you played
that patriot team like 10 times right
yeah i know this is hard for her to say
and you're not this kind of guy like
what do you what do you think 10 times
like what do you think the record would
be there between you two going back and
forth because i thought that was a very
evenly matched super bowl so it would be
it would be i believe it would be closer
to 50 50. yeah right seriously yes
you're like you we lost by about three
points yeah and that with that with a
not healthy t.o yes and so you all those
and andrews are part of the game and we
i don't ever put those in there um but
the the mistakes that we made i always
remember this about that game the
mistakes were the things that we didn't
do in the last four minutes yeah to me
is what sealed the fate of that of that
uh of that and that's offensively and
defensively yeah yeah so you guys you
made some mistakes that were glaring to
you that absolutely that you think
ruined the game for you absolutely yeah
looking at today's nfl brian who do you
see that reminds you of yourself playing
the safety position man you know what i
i don't like to do that because i don't
like to like
kind of put my hand on somebody's head
like this is my little brother-like
thing
i i like
energy
i'm an energy dude and when i see guys
playing the game with that type of
energy and you you're speaking of of
the teams that's they're going to play
in a couple of days you know when you
have a defense
and it's
led by a safety yeah a versatile safety
right and you all know who i'm talking
about honeyback
matthew right the way he plays the game
yeah like there's an energy he brings to
the game and i always say it like this
like when he plays the game the way that
he plays it he invites other people to
his party so now his teammates want to
get involved and have a good time
because of the energy that he can bring
but
to me because he's such a versatile dude
he's just not good in one area he can
cover he can go deep if you want he can
get close to the line of scrimmage he
can blitz so he can do everything that
you can do as a playmaker to cause a
game to turn in your favor that's what i
love about him yeah you uh i mean he is
honey badgers phenomenal that way he's
like you in a lot of ways i mean i'm not
saying he's a hall of famer quite yet
but a quarterback of the defense
absolutely and the emotional leader now
another guy i want to ask you about like
troy polavallo being up for the hall of
fame this year what what about his game
cause he's not like the vocal kind of
guy like you were a honey badger was but
certainly effective like what will you
always remember about his career because
i expect him to be in the hall of fame
as a first ballot guy you know what
troy
he he had instincts to do some of the
things that he did and he had the
freedom the green light to just go right
um you know we will be watching film
sometimes with this joke and he would
have curl flat to the right side of the
field he would line up on the left side
the whole part first part yeah of the
snap
all of a sudden when the ball is snapped
you see him sprinting across the field
to get to the other side yeah or he
would have deep like middle or something
like that and he would see him blitzing
in the a-gap right so he was you know i
heard i saw this online the other day he
was really like almost like the junior
sail yeah safety positions like he was
able to just jump stuff and go get stuff
right but he could do it and he did it
hey before we run out of time you've got
a great cause you're here today on
behalf of canines for warriors.org and
you got one of them with you i always
love it when a dog's around awesome tell
us about it so
i've been blessed to wear the number 20
um
throughout my career and when i caught
wind of this statistic not just this but
this statistic blew me away that um
we lose 20 vets per day to suicide
and so
if we can do anything to help that out
and canines for warriors um is a place
that they can go to to receive or to to
have someone introduced into the family
right because when you get a service dog
i have two dogs myself and they're a
part of the family yeah right i'm with
you and so too absolutely so you know
how that feels you know how you come
home and you're having a bad day and the
dog wants you to like one of my kids
absolutely yeah yeah so think about that
when you're having someone who's dealt
with some of the things that you know
jason has dealt with sure so that he can
come home to help you come down off your
emotions sometimes helps people out of
depression depressive states yeah and so
i want to do everything that i can to
bring awareness to it so that people can
donate at least 20 dollars
to help in this regard we've got to take
a quick break level more on canines for
warriors.org right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports